[Music]
oh I had one of the great [ __ ] old
man moments my life okay so I'm driving
drive it at the Comedy Store I feel
weird trying to even look out at you
guys I'm supposed to be alone this is
like this is like back in the day when I
would stay at like a super rate they
wouldn't have a couch as nice as this
but it wouldn't be like [ __ ] like
long enough so you could lay down on it
so then they'd have to drag some other
[ __ ] piece of furniture over like
this and then stick your legs up my god
this is better this is better than
sleeping in the bed you know John Wayne
Gacy had a [ __ ] threesome with a
couple of oh come on don't don't be like
that don't [ __ ] it be like that alright
so anyway I'm driving down the road I'm
not lying down like this but I'm driving
down the road and I was listening to
Aussie Osbourne yes and I was listening
to some of that brandy Road [ __ ] right
[Music]
pull up I'm going to the Comedy Store
and I'm stopped at a red light on
Crescent Heights and Laurel no that
doesn't make sense Crescent Heights in
Sunset and I'm [ __ ] sitting there
there's an open lane next to me because
it merges in this nobody there and you
know I said my windows down I got it
cranked you know like the old guy that
a.m. and all of a sudden you know we
just feel like somebody looking at you
and I [ __ ] look over and there's a
guy like a year or two older than me on
the sidewalk dressed like he's he what
he was jogging but stopped and he's just
looking at me
and I'm like what the [ __ ] and he starts
air-drumming
to the song
so I'm like my windows are down I don't
want to put the window up because he's
close enough that if that offends him
he's gonna lunge at me with whatever
he's stuck in his arm and then I have
what he has right so I'm trying to
ignore him and he's just I feel I could
just feel the heat of him and I [ __ ]
look over he's still staring he's still
[ __ ] air-drumming
and then I see he crushes all of the
fills like who's [ __ ] crushing it
while he's just looking at me at that
point I just start laughing he never
breaks character the light turns green
and then simultaneously both do the
devil horns don't worry now it's just
like yeah that was like that [ __ ]
awesome
[Applause]